ces derniers jours la pression des élus
américains s'étaient accrues sur la
maison blanche joe biden frappe à
nouveau vladimir poutine au portefeuille
le président américain annonce de
nouvelles sanctions contre moscou après
son invasion de l'ukraine un embargo sur
les importations de pétrole et de gaz
venu de russie première source de
revenus du pays mais pour le peuple
américain veut infliger un nouveau coup
rude à la machine de guerre de poutine
nous avons pris cette décision en
coordination étroite avec nos alliés et
nos partenaires à travers le monde
particulièrement en europe car une
réponse unie à l'agression de poutine a
été ma priorité absolue que l'otan lieux
et nos alliés soient totalement unie
des alliés unis mais pas tout à fait sur
la même longueur d'onde car pour
l'instant lieu elle temporise à l'image
du vice président exécutif de la
commission européenne estime hermance
interrogé ce mardi par france 24 tout
est toujours sur la table je suis sûr
que nos chefs d'état de gouvernement en
reparlerons à versailles jeudi et
vendredi mais quand on impose des
sanctions il faut quand même savoir que
celui auquel on pose ses sanctions et
plus touchés par ces sanctions que celui
qui les imposent
interdire le gaz russe une décision bien
plus difficile à prendre pour lieu car
elle en dépend à près de 40% seulement 8
% pour les etats-unis
premiers producteurs de gaz de schiste
au monde il pourrait bien profiter de
cette mise au banc international du
kremlin pour conquérir de nouveaux
marchés